aquí está la estructura de puntos para
el ácido propano bio ico o ácido mal o
niko y si lo calienta va a experimentar
una reacción de descarboxilasa si
nuestra rotación libre alrededor de este
enlace es un enlace sigma por lo que
podemos mostrar una conformación
distinta y déjame continuar dibujando
este ácido carboxílicos en la izquierda
y luego también tendremos un ácido
carboxílicos en la derecha también esta
vez el carbón y lo irá a la derecha
déjame poner esos electrones
él irá a la izquierda ahí lo tenemos en
este mecanismo de hecho vamos a formar
un enlace entre este oxígeno y este
protón y es un mecanismo psíquico si
estos electrones se mueven acá eso
empujará a estos electrones a acá y
luego estos electrones formarán un
enlace entre el oxígeno y el hidrógeno
continuamos mostrando el resultado de
nuestro mecanismo cíclico tenemos un
carbono unido a un oxígeno unido a un
hidrógeno y luego tenemos un o h por
aquí y luego tenemos este doble enlace
entre este carbono y otro carbono en la
derecha
de hecho formaremos co2 así que déjame
poner un par libre de electrones
en ese oxígeno podemos ver que
formaremos nuestra molécula de dióxido
de carbono por aquí déjame dibujar eso y
sigamos algunos de estos electrones
bien los electrones en magenta justo
aquí se movieron para formar este enlace
para formar nuestro doble enlace para el
co2 y luego estos electrones aquí en
azul entre este carbono y este carbono
se moverán acá para formar este doble
enlace entre este carbono y hay un
carbono aquí
y también hay dos hidrógenos enlazados a
este carbono déjame dibujarlos para que
se vea más claro y luego finalmente
hagamos a estos electrones rojos estos
electrones son los que formarán este
enlace entre el oxígeno y el hidrógeno
hemos formado nuestros co2 y también
formamos unen el ácido bien esto de aquí
es llamado
en all
ha sido
vivimos en vídeos anteriores como el
heno le está en equilibrio con la forma
aceto con la automatización seto en el
esta es de hecho la forma de nolde el
ácido acético y de hecho eso será
nuestro producto déjame continuar
dibujando el ácido acético aquí arriba
aquí tenemos el o h en el lado izquierdo
y luego tendremos un carbono por aquí
con tres hidrógenos unidos a él
esto sería si pensáramos en la forma
acepto la diferencia entre la forma en
all y la ceto es el movimiento de un
protón hay un protón aquí en el oxígeno
y luego uno aquí en el carbono y luego
el doble enlace aquí tenemos el doble
enlace entre los dos carbonos y aquí
hemos movido al doble enlace entre el
carbono y el oxígeno nuevamente hemos
visto cómo hacer eso en vídeos
anteriores y también producimos co2 así
que el dióxido de carbono es el otro
producto para esta reacción la clave
para una reacción de descarboxilasa es
tener un carbón y lo veta a un ácido
carboxílicos por ejemplo aquí está
nuestro ácidos carboxílicos y sabemos
que el carbono junto al ácido
carboxílicos es el carbono alfa y el
carbono junto a ese es el carbono beta
y vimos como este carbón y lo estaba
necesariamente en el mecanismo así que
el hecho de que haya uno
aquí no es ni siquiera necesario lo que
realmente necesitamos es un carbón y lo
que este beta a nuestro ácidos
carboxílicos para que una reacción de
descarboxilasa ocurra
veamos otro ejemplo donde ya no tengamos
un ácido de oico tenemos un ácido
carboxílicos a la derecha y luego aquí a
la izquierda tengo una acetona pero
nuevamente la clave es que aquí hay un
carbono alfa y aquí hay un carbono beta
y tenemos un carbón y lo que es beta o
ácidos carboxílicos y por ende una
reacción de descarboxilasa puede ocurrir
si calentamos esta molécula nuevamente
pensando en el mecanismo rotando
alrededor de este enlace sigma
continuamos dibujando esto nuevamente
tenemos nuestro anillo de benceno y
luego tenemos a nuestro carbón y lo
justo aquí y luego nuevamente tenemos a
nuestro carbón y lo yendo a la derecha
esta vez y luego
por aquí en la izquierda
pensando en nuestro mecanismo otra vez
sabemos que es un mecanismo cíclico
sabemos que este oxígeno se va a enlazar
a este protón y entonces estos
electrones se moverán acá
y estos electrones se moverán a acá
y estos electrones se moverán acá
ese es nuestro mecanismo cíclico
dibujamos y dibujamos lo que ocurrió
dibujando todos esos electrones
tenemos este protón y luego tenemos un
doble enlace justo aquí y también
formamos
otros
nuevamente veamos a los electrones e
intentemos seguir a algunos de esos
electrones aquí déjame dibujar estos
pares libres de electrones en nuestro
oxígeno
podemos ver de dónde viene el co2
nuevamente estos electrones aquí en
magenta se moverán acá
para formar el doble enlace en el co2 al
mismo tiempo estos electrones de aquí se
moverán acá para formar este doble
enlace y luego finalmente estos
electrones de aquí se moverán para
formar el enlace entre el oxígeno y el
hidrógeno
hemos hecho nuestros co2 así que el
oxígeno carbono oxígeno viene de este
oxígeno carbono oxígeno aquí en la
molécula en la izquierda eso es más
fácil de ver ahora y nuevamente tenemos
una enorme formamos nuestro co2 también
creamos nuestro sol
y entonces podemos pensar en
automatización set o en all para nuestro
producto
lennon estará en equilibrio con la forma
set o continuamos dibujando la forma
aceptó la cual sabemos está moviendo un
protón y moviendo un doble enlace
movemos el doble enlace entre el carbono
y el oxígeno y movemos este protón a
este carbono de aquí este carbono de
aquí toma un protón aquí abajo este
carbono tenía dos hidrógenos y no tiene
que ser este de aquí pero añadiremos un
hidrógeno a este carbono y eso nos da
nuestro producto final
nuestra acetona esta reacción de
descarboxilasa produce una cetona y
nuevamente realmente no importa lo que
sea este grupo r
aquí abajo tenemos un anillo de benceno
al lugar de lo del ejemplo anterior y
luego por supuesto también haremos
o dos
las reacciones de descarboxilasa serán
importantes en vídeos futuros donde
sintetizar hemos algunas moléculas
complicadas aquí está el mecanismo
psíquico para eso